well hi everybody um my name is Garrick
and today I'd like to talk about a
package that I wrote uh called epoxy but
first I'd like to tell you a little bit
about my kids
um my daughter Ruth is turning four soon
and my son Auggie is about to turn seven
and 6 going on seven is a a really fun
age it's about the time when you start
to ask questions like Dad how much money
do you
make or recently okay so tell me you sit
in front of a computer all day and you
type on it and then they give you
money and I was thinking about this
because I I ran into a data set on on
the Tidy Tuesday project about child
care cost um did you
know that infant daycare in the United
States costs up to
were made in the process of grouping and
summarizing and aggregating and
calculating this
statistic and uh that's a very valid
question as someone who spent a lot of
time thinking about how data scientists
write reports and spending time building
tooling for data scientists to to to
write reports and build apps um when I
ask how did that number get there I'm
thinking very specifically like how did
that number get there right I'm
imagining somebody sitting down at a
word processor and they start typing
infant daycare costs up
to and how much does it cost and then
they maybe open up a spreadsheet and
they uh find the cell where they did the
calculation and they copy it and then
they come back here and they paste
it a year okay cool that's how much it
cost a year um I like to imagine a data
scientist who is working in our markdown
and they're writing this in kind of the
same way they write the sentence infant
daycare costs up to but when they get to
this point they have some extra context
available to them in this our markdown
report just a little bit above this
sentence there's a code chunk where
they've been doing this calculation they
took child care costs and they grouped
and summarized and filtered and they
came up with a number and they called
that they put it in a variable and they
called that variable Max median cost
already you know something more than you
did before about that number because we
see the label that it was given when we
saved when we saved that number to a
variable
and having this context they can take
that variable and use ours inline uh
code syntax right to embed the max
median cost of child care right into the
sentence with a little back tick R and
then the variable and another back tick
this is the power and the promise and
and just what makes uh our markdown
wonderful right that you can work with
your data and also talk about it
summarize it report on it describe it to
other people here in the same place
right um it's kind of like a source
document for the report right and and at
some point you hit the render button and
you get this amazing this amazing
sentence yeah infant daycare costs up to
1. 541 696 and then that part the little
bit at the end means like times 10
raised to the fourth power this doesn't
make any sense doesn't hit in the same
way as this
statistic this problem of what happens
right before of of formatting things in
a way that um is is readable and useful
is H is exactly the problem that epoxy
is trying to
solve it gives you an inline syntax that
makes it easy to use just in time
formatting so you can say that that
thing should be uh formatted as a
currency and as a result we also get to
use some of knitter's powerful tools
like these chunks to create little
templates that we can reuse throughout
our
document if this hex sticker looks
familiar to
you it's because epoxy is built on
another really cool r package called
glue glue is really really cool and
we'll see the Syntax for glue and and
like how glue Powers
epoxy but glue has a different target
audience glue is made primarily for
developers um it's very lightweight so
developers can feel comfortable bringing
it into their packages it has no
dependencies um which means that it's
kind of limited it's pretty good in
files that end in r or places where
you're writing R scripts
right aoxy on the other hand takes the
assumption that um we're providing a
tool for data
scientists you're or we we will build on
packages that you're probably already
using to do the formatting
and um and then you can use epoxy in a
bunch of different ways to kind of make
glue more powerful for you in in our
scripts in reports like R mark down in
cardo and in shiny apps we're going to
see a little bit of all three of those
things
today okay let's go back to our sentence
infant daycare cost this is the the um
the r markdown version and we're going
to turn this into an epoxy version the
first step is to put the whole thing in
into a chunk an epoxy chunk this is kind
of like an R chunk except what's inside
is going to be marked
down um once we've done that we can now
use epoxy Syntax for inline code instead
of the back ticks r space expression
back tick we wrap the expression in
curly braces you can even say we embrace
the
expression and then the final little bit
of flare is to say how we want this this
thing to be formatted so we add dollar
borrowing from some syntax that I
learned from the CLI
package dollar says format this as a
currency when we render
this you get um a nicely formatted um
sentence a
number okay let's step back and see how
this magic works just a little bit when
you're using glue glue works great for
um for Strings it's a little bit like
paste except it has it uses this
embracing Sy sytax to mark an expression
and it'll go find Max median cost in
your global environment and fill it in
it doesn't do much formatting though but
it does give us a key that epoxy Builds
on and that's the um Transformer
argument so normally the identity
Transformer is the normal thing that
glue does and it basically says find
this variable and replace it with its
value epoxy steps in here and uses the
Transformer argument to provide its own
Logic for what should happen when we see
these embraced
expressions and that lets us do things
like use the dollar syntax and now we
have a for a number formatted like a
dollar and of course this is a lot of
stuff that you don't want to type every
time you use um epoxy so epoxy wraps it
all up into one function called
epoxy and this also then Powers the
chunk the epoxy chunk all right let's
see some of these other things that you
can do with these inline formatting
syntaxes right so we saw that if you
have a number that should be a a
currency or a dollar unit right we can
use that dollar and we get a you know
number form like a
dollar if you have a number between zero
and one that should look like a
percentage you can say do percent and
it's formatted like a
percentage a very large number that
should probably have some commas to tell
you where uh the placeholders
are you can use. comma epoxy isn't just
for um numbers you can also use it for
text suppose you have oh wait no there
it is there's one more number thing and
that is a is an ordinal so this is
something like saying uh first second
third fourth
Etc and then it's not just for numbers
it's also for text it's pretty cool that
you can do things like take a character
string and say I want this to be
formatted in title
case you could take a string and say I
would like it to be
bold you could take another string and
say I'd like this to be italic
okay let's put this all together into
like a statistic a real sentence that
kind of actually that uses all these
things that make sense we'll throw it in
a blender and we get this first we start
with a chunk we call that it's the epoxy
Chunk we give it a label this time we're
going to give it a label of cost summary
so remember that we're going to come
back to that in a second and in here
I'll just use the Embrace syntax with
these little dot um
Transformers and I can write infant
daycare in very large counties ranks
first in child care costs at 15,41
1696 per year or 24% of median household
income okay that's pretty cool it's nice
um I like it I like parts of it but
there's a couple little things that are
bugging me still and we're going to fix
those the first one is that
15,400 something dollarss is uh it's
kind of it's a big number and I would
like to you know Express this in terms
of how much is that per month what is
the like monthly budget of of child care
cost so to do that you would take you
know 15,000 and whatever and divide it
by 12 you might like you might write a
little function to do that take x
divided
12 and if you give it to uh another
function called epoxy transform set with
a little name like. CPM you've now
created your own inline Transformer that
you can use so if I go back to my
sentence I can add a phrase like about
CPM median Max cost per month which
turns into
12,800 uh
something it's not right but we'll get
there hold
on so you can actually format that like
a dollar also by adding another level of
embracing and um and now we have
1,284 the previous side slide should
have said 1, to4 as well but just
without the decoration of
dollars um but yeah so you can you can
compose these so you can have multiple
Transformations as you get as you like
move from the number to the thing that
you uh actually want to
show and you know we could do even more
and we could add Bolder italic around
that as
well the these dollar and percent and
the other ones that we saw that are like
um built in with epoxy are basically
just functions as well they come from
packages that we use already and that we
know like the scales package so doll
really is just labeled dollar from the
scales package and perent is label per
from the scales
package um so now we get to the other
little thing that's bugging me about
this is like do we really need to
include the number of cents in our you
know summary of per year right um but
maybe I do want a little bit more
accuracy in terms of the percentage
because I'm comparing between counties
uh so and the you know the median
household income you know know I wanted
to sound really official so like we need
another decimal point before that
percentage so label dollar and label
percent have um have arguments and you
can say I want dollars rounded the
nearest 100 and label percent you can
say I want that rounded to the nearest I
want to show at least you know 0.1 um so
now we have 23.8% in median household
income and we have about
$1,300 per month that's a lot of money
that number Hits differently than uh
than our original statistic did
right so so far I've been kind of
pretending like these um you know these
variables come from the global
environment and they could you could be
calculating each one of these and you
could put that save them in a variable
or something but most likely you're
going to put this in a data frame right
you have a you have a data frame you've
been using that to set you know to
summarize and um and you can see now I
this whole time have actually been
sneakily using a data frame and you can
see the columns um that uh that we we've
seen so far like Max median cost right
there in the middle and
age so if I would like to have this um
epoxy chunk use a data frame say a row
from the data frame perhaps the first
row from the data frame I can use the
data chunk option and give it a data
frame or a row from a data frame here's
the first one this is the same uh you
know stat that we saw uh so far
and if I wanted to for example compare
infant daycare with infant home care
then I could go back and look at this
table and say oh it's row number eight
and I can change the data argument to
row number eight and now epoxy is going
to take that row and apply the um apply
the the the values in that row of the
data frame to the template and now the
the chunk itself kind of looks more like
a template
that we can
reuse most people however don't really
uh like you know having to use uh chunk
options as a way to interface with this
and certainly you're not going to just
be like oh I want the eighth row right
that's not how we think about this
instead what you would do is you take
your child care
summary you pipe it into Deer filter you
say age I want a where age is infant
where type is home care where County
size is very large
right and imagine this is in an R Chunk
in your document and we have that other
um epoxy chunk that we talked about
earlier that has the label cost summary
so I can pipe this data frame which has
one row into aoxy Ed chunk tell it to
use the chunk with a label cost summary
and now rerender that sentence uh using
these new
values there we
go
uh sometimes you uh don't write and just
markdown so the epoxy chunks we've been
seeing so far assume that what is in
that chunk is basically markdown uh but
sometimes you need to actually write
HTML or you're writing an HTML report
and you want the stuff coming out of
these epoxy chunks to be HTML sometimes
you might be writing in uh in latch and
you um you know need to write some lat
Tech if you have to and uh in both cases
epoxy gives you two a chunk types we
have an epoxy HTML chunk engine and an
epoxy latch chunk
engine um they have slightly different
semantics just a little bit it's just
tweaked enough to make it really make
sense for that language so in HTML it's
double embracing and instead of dot bold
we would use at
bold what you get though is you get
actual HTML instead of markdown
formatting for bold for example in latch
it's uh basically the same except uh the
embrac characters are kind of taken
already in latex so we use um Chompy
alligator things and we put that around
County size we can still use bold and um
in the end you
get uh whatever that is that latch uses
to make bold
text okay all of these chunks are
powered by our functions ultimately so
under the hood you can um you can just
easily call this in R so we have an
epoxy function epoxy HTML epoxy latch um
epoxy itself is basically kind of like a
drop-in replacement for glue with all
the these extra fun little
bits um but because we don't have chunks
in uh in in the r console or in R script
you can also use epoxy use file and read
a template from a
file so we've seen how you can use epoxy
and reports our markdown quarter reports
mark down HTML latch outputs we've seen
epoxy and scripts kind of I mean you get
the idea right we can use it with um
these three functions and I really can't
talk a posic conf without mentioning my
favorite web framework of all
time shiny so let me show you a shiny
app in in this case epoxy brings these
same ideas to a shiny app uh with a
little bit of a Twist so it's not quite
the same as what we've seen but it's
kind of the same idea so here's a shiny
app don't try to read all the code
please it just does it makes it you know
it makes a little app like this we have
three inputs where we get greeting
company and year and then we have a
section that we Mark with UI epoxy HTML
we give it an ID so we can find it and
inside of that we can just put um shiny
things uh UI elements labels pretty much
anything here I picked uh p and you can
see uh kind of the template so it's
making a paragraph tag and there's some
stuff written in there and you can see
the kind of the template for it um
those we have greeting company and year
right so on the server side we match um
we take render epoxy match that to the
the ID of the template which was hello
and then we send it some things that are
end going to end up being text and they
come out at the bottom um or they come
out in the in the paragraph tag over
here hello R Studio
oh hello
picom
so that's a pretty quick summary of uh
what epoxy does there's a whole lot more
that it can do um and uh just to remind
you what we talked about epoxy is a
great way to blend data and Pros build
on the ideas of our markdown it gives
you reusable templates just in time
formatting use it in your reports and
your scripts and your apps um generally
just go have fun with it and uh and uh
you can find it here and online in
general and thank you very
much